ballet diplomatique devant le palais de
dolmabahçe ukrainiens russes se
rencontrent pour une nouvelle série de
pourparlers la dernière c'était le 10
mars dernier et elle n'avaient rien
donné au 34e jours de guerre le
président turc compte bien jouer les
médiateurs
parvenir à un cessez le feu et à la paix
le plus tôt possible et dans l'intérêt
de tous les progrès que la furie ans les
négociations rendent également possible
la prochaine étape une rencontre entre
dirigeants nous sommes également prêts à
accueillir une
rencontre au sommet entre les deux
présidents russe et ukrainien
volodimir zelensky l'appel de ces deux
mais moscou sens opposé une fin de
non-recevoir définitive repousse
l'échéance à 2 ans au delà des murs
poutine a dit qu'il ne refuserai jamais
droite président
le conflit à l'intérieur de l'ukraine
school depuis si longtemps des années
beaucoup de problèmes se sont accumulés
que tous se rencontrer et se dire qu'est
ce que tu penses et moi je pense que je
serai juste votre productivité
moscou pose aussi plusieurs conditions à
cette rencontre la démilitarisation et
la neutralité de l'ukraine ce qu'elle
qualifie de dénazification du pays ainsi
que la reconnaissance par kiev de
l'annexion de la crimée par la russie en
2014 ou encore l'indépendance des
républiques pro-russe du dombass
quelques heures avant côté ukrainien
volodimir zelensky s'était dit prêt à
des compromis et pas des moins y'a pas
ni moi je comprends qu'il est impossible
de forcer complètement là réussi à
quitter le territoire ukrainien cela
conduirait à la troisième guerre
mondiale
je le comprends et c'est pourquoi je
parle d'un compromis ni disque d'assur
retourner là où tout a commencé et
ensuite nous essaierons de résoudre le
problème du dombass la question
compliquée du dombass
le cren se dit aussi prête à un
compromis sur la question de sa non
adhésion à l'otan mais exige un cessez
le feu immédiat et le retrait des
troupes russes